[Music]
I've got some good news for you so now
you can listen to JK news on podcast so
check the description box below you
could check out those links and if
you're on the bus listening on a car
listening walking around listening you
could just listen now it's gonna be
really cool so check it out and make
sure you rate it and don't forget to
listen listen baby alright welcome guys
- off the record or we talk about
whatever have you guys been good but
you've been traveling around like a
[ __ ] we got so many stories I
know someone just happen in a horde that
we start where do you want to start I'll
let you talk for you star you travel the
world even going to like it's nothing
you have to I don't know where the [ __ ]
you been you know you went to where all
the Jesus places were oh he's great no I
was gone for 21 days
[ __ ] that's unreal just gonna stop it
right there how when was the - long day
oh I think so we we got to come home
halfway through cuz we for a game which
day did you have the first fight purfles
always fight on trips no matter what
even before the triple that what it
looks like on Instagram we always fight
like you're you're this picture and then
if you're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ]
but later you look at the video or
picture you're like man that was a good
trip I know right so what was the date
it was like [ __ ] this is a lot of travel
and when was the first fight we ended up
like halfway through the whole trip we
stopped in LA for only six hours cuz the
first half of the Morocco trip that was
a planned first and then the Istria trip
came after so then that's why we had to
come here so the whole flight thing was
whole mess by the time we landed here or
like we left Morocco we already felt
like ah [ __ ] this is ready pretty long
that was ready I think about 12 days
yeah she had a whole other half a trip
down and then so by then luckily though
I mean the really long flights of 13
hour flights we got business way better
yeah so it was so sweet we got to just
leave lay flat and actually rest but the
whole airplane area really did a lot of
[ __ ] to my nostrils but yeah I get sinus
pressure shits now for me it's the
dryness I have to get going to the
bathroom and you know the business
Kasich evolutions and stuff in the
sciences going in oh that's good all you
know I don't like this oh that's coach
that's pretty coach problem cuz I was
using what nature gave me oh yeah your
weekend whatever nature gave you is
[ __ ] up and I like how you could have
just like verbally exploited you just
had to show us you know just drink a lot
of water
hey you know there he goes again it's
working I kept giving us bottles and
like I used to get that too and I just
drink a lot of water and it does
disappeared it does it's like I'm
hanging with my mom right you're not
drinking enough water is your problem
water does wonders
I agree now I got my body used to
drinking so much more water for you now
at this point I feel really I did get
the whole bottle a week now really
interesting also because of the Morocco
trip we were with 13 other strangers you
guys get diarrhea let her finish I'm
getting juicy [ __ ] a little Seco can you
please consider yellow Cinco I'm asking
question I'm asking good questions no we
didn't get the area
luckily oh now what are the
conversations gonna have she said no no
what she yelling in my ear oh but you're
interrupted she says but luckily and
then you fault you you come
I'm adding onto your interrupting let's
just tell tip how our trip went okay you
had good time in Morocco I just didn't
know what what la Cinco means LOC Co
it's like an animal mouth and only mouth
on an animal Yoshiko
Oh Seco Seco that's [ __ ] tight I'm
using that I'm say what so Seco a mouth
on an animal go [ __ ] [ __ ]
let's not want to be a dog's mouth he
sucks his own dick don't you say you
wanted to try and do that oh no that was
you huh how what happened on your trip
uh there's just so much that happened I
don't know yeah like dealing with
strangers I was interesting that's tight
what the hell happened there what the
[ __ ] no cuz I had never traveled with
strangers before and not really yeah
never
I've never pretty awful I just pictured
you like an alleyway in there like hello
little one like a gypsy came out with a
crystal ball would you like to see your
fortune I saw a lot in the whole time
the flying carpet and they're like oh my
god you're like stealing bread for
little kids one jump ahead of the bread
line you're in a market you pick up a
lamp you like idiots make wishes already
she reminds me of Princess Jasmine and
then she's like the whole cover the head
cover and I was like oh my god like now
you're hurt I got so many messages from
the photo on my snapchat where I had the
hijab and people just kept telling me
you now you look like jasmine oh my god
you have to put a head job on or else
they go hey woman what the [ __ ] you have
your hair open no but you know is
interesting so we got there the first
week of Ramadan right and so I had I'm
so ignorant I don't know anything about
you start eating in front of everybody
yeah cuz I heard like the parrot call I
didn't know what it was I was like what
is that yeah but then a lot of people
educated me and I'm like oh cool and
then I even asked the tour guy could use
Muslim and he was like he was also
fasting and he was just teaching us a
lot about that's like if I'm with my mom
over there like she called the front
desk of the hotel bed excuse me there's
a noise outside
like it's some religious ceremony I
don't care what it is it's loud like
your tour guide is like the worst tour
guide ever it's so weak we have food
people like taken in front of em like oh
yeah this is a really cool building may
I have the loudness so I could swish my
mother's spit about this the dude hold
it is actually healthier for your body
like your do you teach yourself like
controlled and intermittent fasting yeah
yeah and then uh what else yeah like I
don't know he's just you wrote camels
that was fun fun we did like a whole
hour ride to the campsite we got to
campus your vagina hurt no my bogna do
you know that camels came straight up
eat cactus what with the prickly pears
the spines and everything they just made
cactus oh tight on you disgusting who
when cactus figure out what to do to
defend themselves against the camels is
what I'm gonna be worth like what's the
next step
yeah cuz they already involved to
protect us against everything else
except for camels because camels evolved
to eat the [ __ ] cactus interesting
why they want to eat look it up right
now but it's like a turtle my fur I had
a [ __ ] desert tortoise we would get
the cactus and watch that [ __ ]
he'd just be like turtle eat a cactus I
couldn't sit there leave anything that
was yeah it's like the way it's the top
of its mouth plate and the tongue of the
wall so why do the cactus have [ __ ]
why do they have them then what they
just can't protect yourself against
can't against other things I guess
everybody else everything else but the
camel and the tortoise I guess I mean
the little worms dude they don't give a
[ __ ] y'all go straight on the cactus -
Wow alright cactus you're [ __ ] up
cactus facts yeah but they never spit I
never saw him spit they did team poop a
lot
but Billy spanked I heard they spanked
didn't stink no I mean the part shampoo
these camels for the tour
I'm a camel before you didn't wear a
Zeus no I don't even know I was a child
I just remember camels and then you want
so you don't even know if you wrote it I
know I wrote it because all souls on it
but I don't know where like you know
when you're little parents just take you
places was it moving yeah yeah I
remember being sat on it put a corner in
and plays a song I think the question is
not that is where you allowed to move
like this and that's it no but I
remember being pissed because I wanted
the camel with the two humps but then I
got the camel with one huh yeah cuz I
wanted to ride with you know people and
stuff yeah you got the environmentally
for anyone I cut the one hope one yeah
so did you diarrhea or not she said no
did you [ __ ] in the hole
no that's adventurous where do they not
have to listen don't they of the places
you went right yeah they do have the
whole ones but they also has a regular
okay also I just sat on the regular oh
do they have an option in there like no
but I feel like I didn't get diarrhea
because we just kept brushing our teeth
and just only doing bottle water stuff
we never did I would have [ __ ] had
diarrhea the first day I do the spices
are crazy that's right her know crazy
and it was kissing I feel like we got
the Walmart version of the whole
experience because we just only had
great deals everywhere no great value
huh
falling crisis in great dishes it was
only like the sea otter Jean and
couscous and that was like mainly it
cookies are awesome yeah we get couscous
at lemonade over here in LA what's
couscous thank like rice or like corn
type of grain that's high in protein
yeah we ate it you probably didn't you
didn't have a cooking class on how to
make tez Union where it's like this
really cool clay pot that looks like
this and then you like they taught us
how to stack everything and it was
pretty cool what's a gin tagine it's
like teen you can't get away from the
heat no I kept thinking if I came to
like do these thank you it means the
food though it's the vessel
not with the actual dish they call it as
you what is the tagine oh you can make
it with chicken or beef or you think
they stack up chicken and they put a
whole bunch of spices and then the whole
bunch of vegetables and then they steam
it in that vessel clay pot type of
veggies it's like a Middle Eastern
casserole any press hmm yes kind of we
had it before I don't know
have you huh she doesn't know your life
Joe what the [ __ ] I don't know I gave
Middle Eastern food but I just order do
you often feel a bit different though
yes not merely Africa when we're in Bali
Africa oh cool we've been in Africa when
we're in Bali think you did one of those
like learn the local cuisine things but
it's so [ __ ] hot in Bali and then
she's standing over a grill so she's
like like learning the local cuisine
like looking at me and I'm in the
[ __ ] pool but she wanted to learn the
local thing so bad but she was looking
at me like and she's like dripping was
like so much water coming off of her and
she's like why did I do this
it looks delish yeah incredible I was
like backstroke like [ __ ] spitting
water up they fed me and then I got to
go back in the pool after and she was
like it was like it was like she had
just jumped out of the pool
I was higher than her it was awesome
that's what she gets we'll try to be
active and the food was good at spot by
the way oh yeah this is great
what did you get with your sweat it was
delicious
no I wanna I want to go to that side of
the world
no no whatever says like hey let's go to
Croatia let's go to Morocco you know in
dinner party was like let's go to like
England is boring would you do this what
you did that's all you need to do after
that you're fun you're like not what yes
look you are yeah we were
few hours and I'm like cool weekend in
New York you've been to England I'm dead
serious
I'm like it's the same [ __ ] exact Jam
like it just feels the same same kind of
food around yep deal with it suck it I
don't care like it really is the same
kind of food right I'm so tired of major
cities now because no matter where you
go in the world it's the same [ __ ] it's
just shopping but I want look like Dubai
but Dubai like nuts
cuz I heard they have like a ski resort
inside of a mall in the desert oh my Wow
looks like Vegas is doing cocaine yeah
dude it looks tight they have a water
park in a mall you just said you wanna
go away from major cities I'm agreeing
with him but Dubai is a different thing
it's not a major city it's like a new
the different planet cuz all major
cities are pretty much the same across
the board Dubai is like going to Elysium
you know I'm saying no poor people out
or you're [ __ ] out of here come on
they have gold - oh you for being poor
you know I'm saying yeah and just let
all of us plebeians walk around and like
pretend that we're poor I mean rich rule
we pretend we're rich oh yeah no
honestly that for the next JK company
true we have to go to history on that
places gorge that part Croatia
yeah so it's a region we have perhaps do
you have crabs particularly okay because
the casino does nothing for me if they
don't have craps my dick doesn't get
hard I don't know but they did see a lot
of slot machine ads and stuff but yeah
that place is so beautiful like the
beaches are quarry I so history I used
to be part of Italy so it felt like we
went to Italy but like untouched Italy I
don't even know what I think Croatia I
think like Eastern Europe
I think Game of Thrones no no they shot
a lot that stuff there and also think of
Mirko Cro Cop or crow cause the only
thing I think about cocoa yeah Nogueira
translocation in Morocco so do you
remember when Khaleesi became Khaleesi
yeah like spoiler slaver
hey it wasn't slavers big burning tent
no it was like that super dope as gay I
think it's like the first time I'll show
you the photo later but we got to see
that place it's a unicycle Heritage
World Heritage Site and it's like mud
created like city or something it was
beautiful I still it sounds like
something I'm driving through Alabama
man it's like come see the city made of
mud yeah okay
I want to see the city made of mind yeah
it sounds tired yeah I know one of our
tour guides like keep picking up he
picked up like a piece like a leftover
piece of Fabio's like all this was from
when they filmed hey you live there I
think there's a hotel in there too I
would I want to stay in a mud hut like
for a day yeah you want to build and
stay in your own mud huh that's what you
want who's doing your own oh you don't
have one you can't afford to make this
happen I know might not dream you can
man I think you can do it definitely I
know there's like land out here in a
Cali desert where it's pretty much free
you just gotta pay for the utilities and
I can create a mud hut there but I got a
driving like an hour - have you seen the
one in Pasadena well looks like it's in
like I don't know if it is but it's like
a dome I always drive by it it's so
crazy
I'm like really muttered oh yeah it
wasn't the castle
what's the castle in Pasadena or not Pez
Adina in my Glendale there's a [ __ ]
castle dude right there Magic Castle
wait the one on the hill you can see
from the freeway yes I always pass it on
my way here I saw it again this morning
I was like ah [ __ ] what is this the one
where they shot a bunch of movies it's
like a big-ass mansion look in the PAP
testing ask him I don't know you I'm
asking you
look who's used to hook up the JK
adventures to problem-solving so I was
like is it nothing that we do that so
Middle Eastern Prince built a castle
here to live in and it's like a medieval
castle easy a min Eastern Middle Eastern
princes he Bollywood money Prince well I
don't know big castle before bedtime
magician [ __ ] no I'm yeah I [ __ ] hate
it I got invited yeah I like magic you
like magic no I heard people are
pretentious as [ __ ] over there it's not
only that it's just like I'm just
walking around in this guy and there's
like 12 people in there right and
they're not working there there's no I
guess like it's like a guild like a
magician's guild yeah right so you walk
up in the gut and people just come up to
you would you'd like to see some magic
and I might absolutely not yeah
there because I went because Marilyn
wanted to go so just do it so you're
there to ruin it for her
you are you fun killer no it's just
because it's the same card trick over
and over and over it's like I don't want
to see I want to see some crazy [ __ ]
you're heckling the magician magician
heckle I just absolutely no absolutely
not I love magic dude I was in a David
Copperfield trick in Vegas oh we got
picked to go up on stage yeah and and
basically somebody he did somebody just
sued about this trick too and I was
actually in this trick so somebody's ass
sued David Copperfield cuz they were
part of the trick and they got injured
but I was one of the people who was up
on stage like witnessing the trick right
but they have it set up so that the
whole audience disappears and then they
reappear like in the back of the room so
there's like this huge auditorium in it
but they just rotate the room right no
no no they they just it's so funny how
magic is like you know [ __ ] scars and
[ __ ] it's like you know it he comes out
and he's like he's like do you ever have
a dream you know what I mean and he's
like he's like sometimes we all want to
just disappear and he takes a [ __ ]
scar from you but it's so funny that the
reality is like he's like okay presto
whatever and then the [ __ ] audience
is like grabbed by stage hands and they
[ __ ] bring a jet way you know like
those foldable jet ways that yeah expand
out and they collapse they they just
connect a jet way to the side of the
stage and there's a mirror in front of
it and then everyone's just like getting
pulled through there by stage hands like
[ __ ] it run and so they're all running
in a tunnel that's built underneath the
auditory and then they just and then
they just stand there a part of the tray
part of the trick and then they're
they're sworn to secrecy at the end of
the show so my girlfriend at the time
you breaking that secrecy swear
absolutely [ __ ] yeah because because I
think it actually got broken because the
of this lawsuit
so people are running and they got hurt
somebody got hurt because she tripped
the exact trampled I hope so
trampled during a magic trick no she
lived to sue right yeah and so yeah then
they up here at the back and then David
Copperfield like comes up to you and
he's like hi I'm David I'll sign you
your [ __ ] little thing don't tell
anybody my trick okay like that's what
we told my Elphaba and so yeah but that
I've been I've been part of a magic
trick like they're [ __ ] cool but when
you see the behind-the-scenes nuts and
bolts of it it's like damn it's like
gross it's like it's like gross manic
city it's like scuzzy it's like I don't
know something about like those card
tricks like it loses his novelty after
the first one you know so like once I
saw it once and then like seven other
people that would you'd like to see it
magic
absolutely not what about that David
Blanche to reassign it and he [ __ ] him
throws and it's on the other side of the
glass well they were doing that [ __ ] it
was more like that how about wooden they
get handcuffed and thrown in some
[ __ ] water and they bout to die and
then they get out of that [ __ ]
the only magician that I like there was
this older guy he's like 70 years old
but he was like a comedian and he's just
busting jokes the whole oh I like those
guys it was cracking the [ __ ] up did you
see the one with david blaine did did
tricks to Harrison Ford no I always
thought like okay well look what you
just said they probably have an audience
plant who's there and they're like whoa
I didn't know how did you know my name
or how did you know my [ __ ] dead
dad's name or whatever well they got
Harrison Ford to like peel and orange
and like the answer was inside a [ __ ]
orange that he peeled on in his kitchen
I'm like you can't get Harrison Ford to
do this [ __ ] like he wouldn't be in on
your bid David Blaine does that weird
[ __ ] where he'll like swallow a frog and
throw it up again like he does that type
of [ __ ] yeah and he smells a dead frog
and throws it up and it's alive what was
i in formaldehyde he swallowed the tap
water comes out of full throw comes out
a pregnant frog yeah
[Music]